AND WE HAVE A QUORUM I WANT
TO WELCOME YOU TO THE JANUARY
FOURTEENTH HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES OUR
FIRST HEARING FOR THE NEW
YEAR I WANT TO REMIND YOU
THAT WE ARE THE COMMITTEE
OF TWO TWO WITNESSES FOR TWO
WITNESSES AGAINST TWO MINUTES
EACH SO I ALSO WANT TO TAKE
SOME TIME NOW TO INTRODUCE
OUR NEW CHIEF CONSULTANT
DEBORAH COOPER WELCOME DEBORAH
MS COOPER COMES TO US WITH
OVER FIVE YEARS OF LEGISLATIVE
SERVICE AND WE ARE EXCITED
FOR THIS NEW YEAR TOGETHER
THEY WERE GOING TO BE WORKING
ON -- WE HAVE ONE MATTER
ON CONSENT TO HAVE A MOTION
THANK YOU MOTION SECOND AND
LET'S ESTABLISH THE COURT
THANK YOU MISTER STONE
RAY S. HERE MATHIS
ARAMBULA CHOI FRIEDMAN
GIPSON MAIENSCHEIN STONE
WE HAVE A QUORUM OFFICIALLY
ALL RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A
MOTION THEN ON THE CONSENT
RIGHT MADAM SECRETARY
JUST TAKE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR RADIUS
HI MY S. I MATHIS ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I CHOI CHOICE I
FRIEDMAN GIPSON GIPSON I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
EYES STONE STONE I
SIX TO THREE SIX
ZERO THAT MATTER
WE BUT WE DO HAVE SOME ABSENT
MEMBERS WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS MR FLORA
ON AB THREE SIXTY SEVEN YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
WANT TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
AND WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE STAFFER WORK WITH
MY STAFF TO GETTING THOSE DONE
I'LL KEEP THIS VERY SHORT AB
THREE SIXTY SEVEN WITH A BILL
TO REQUIRE RECOMMENDATION OF
THE STATE AUTHORED BY SUCH
MEANS SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
CRIMES TO THE EXISTING LIST
OF CRIMES THAT MAKE A PERSON
INELIGIBLE TO BECOME A CARE
GIVER AB THREE SIXTY SEVEN
WOULD INSURE WE PROTECT
THE MOST PANEL VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS FROM OUR SOCIETY
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE
I MISSED FLORA DO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR WORKING WITH COMMITTEE
ON THIS IT'S AN IMPORTANT
BILL THAT WILL PROVIDE A
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE NEEDED
THANK YOU THE PROJECT THAT I'M
WHAT'S AT
ISSUE NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
GOOD AFTERNOON MADELINE COOPER
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF
SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
MAX PRIVATE THE CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION
AWESOME SUPPORT THANK YOU
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
DENNIS CUEVAS ROMERO WITH
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AND
REGRETFUL OPPOSITION TO THE
PROPOSED BILL -- WE ACCEPT
WE APPLAUD DR FOR TAKING THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS -- SIMPLY
WE ARE CONCERNED BY HAVING A
BLANKET APPROACH TO THESE ADDED
IN THESE ADDITIONAL CRIMES THAT
WE MAY BE HARMING THE FOLKS
THAT WERE TRYING TO PREVENT
BY LIMITING THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE ACTUALLY VOLUNTEERING FOR
THIS SO WE HOPE TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH AUTHORS OFFICE AND
WHERE REGRETTABLY IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
SAYING NONE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A FIRST OR
SECOND PLEASE TAKE ROLE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RIGHT YES HI RES I
AM MATHIS ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
AYE CHOI CHOI I FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON GIPSON AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN ICE
STONE STONE I SEVEN SEVEN
ZERO WHAT WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS BUT
THINK ABOUT OBVIOUSLY IT'S OUT
THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT REAGAN
ADMINISTRATION TO
MS FREEMAN -- LET'S ADD YOU ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH IT
DOES TAKE WRONG ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
I CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO
THANK YOU
STONE THAT'S SOMETHING
YEAH COME AND GET
RIGHT
YEAH
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR MATHIS
MATHIS I'VE FINAL VOTE EIGHT TO
ZERO FILE ITEM ONE A. B.
THREE SIXTY SEVEN CURRENT VOTE
SEVEN TO ZERO MATHIS MATHIS I
FINAL VOTE EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU
MISTER MATHIS MISTER VICE CHAIR
SPENDING IS ADJOURNED
LOCAL PTA